Good morning Hank, it's Monday.
I think we should do a theme week this week, and I think the theme should be open letters
to our fifteen year old brothers.
By the way "Do you like my shirt?" is a rhetorical question, of course you like it.
Dear fifteen-year-old Hank,
Hi, it's me, John Green, your brother! I know I look old.
15 year old Hank, life is a lot like pizza.
Here´s a question:
Is pizza American?
Or is it Italian, or Greek, or Brazilian where they eat more pizza than anyone in the whole world?
More than 6000 pizzerias in Brazil.
6000 ! You can eat at a different pizzeria in Brazil every day for 18 years!
Before you had to go to a place twice.
Unless you were eating pizza twice a day
which, let's face it, I would be.
So Hank, you're 15
and like a lot of fifteen year olds, you feel like when you are forced to read books in English class and look for metaphor
and symbolism and theme and all that stuff, you are sort of being tortured.
By the way, fifteen year old Hank. I am now an author.
Huh?
Here's what critical reading does Hank: it helps us understand what to think about and it gives us a framework for how to think about those things.
Okay, so let me give you an easy to comprehend example for what I'm talking about from this famously incomprehensible James Joyce novel, Ulysses.
I'm getting to the pizza.
So there's this Irish Jewish guy Bloom and he's sitting in a bar and one of the guys he's talking to, John Wyse, says:
"But do you know what a nation means?"
"A nation?", says Bloom, "A nation is the same people living in the same place."
And then everybody starts to make fun of Bloom for his stupid definition, and then Bloom adds: "Or also living in different places."
But then as the characters in the novel are laughing at Bloom, the reader
realizes that, you know, we don't have a better definition
for what constitutes a nation.
Or indeed what it means to have membership in any community.
I mean, Bloom is in this weird in-between space because he's Irish
but he's also Jewish, which many characters in the novel see as inherently un-Irish.
But ultimately we all want to feel like we're on the inside of our communities
whether it's Ireland or the United States or a high school clique or
Nerdfighteria. And the question of whether there have to be
outsiders in order for there to be insiders turns out to be a really interesting and difficult and complicated
question, which is explored at length in Ulysses.
And thinking about, as the guys at the bar clearly can't, what we really mean when we talk about
these identifiers, is a much better starting place for
conversations about who is or is not American. Or who is or is not a Nerdfighter,
rather than the current method of discourse which is just to be like:
Ahhh I´m a Giant Squid of Anger, I do not listen to you!
That form of communicating hurts not only the quality of discourse, but also the quality of my glasses.
Which brings me to pizza
Hank, is pizza American?
Certainly there's a lot of pizza in America. Thank goodness.
Hmmmm, pizza
But pizza was originally Italian, although Italian pizza doesn't taste very much like this because this pizza is fortified with sodium
which is a mineral, or a vitamin. All I know is that it's good for you. In fact Hank, pizza is so ubiquitous,
it's a little bit difficult to say what pizza even is.
I mean, sometimes it comes without cheese, sometimes it comes without sauce,
sometimes it comes without a crust in a bucket.
And people are the same way, Hank. A nation is the same people living in the
same place or also in different places. There are Italians in Italy and there are Italians in America, and there are Italians of Chilean descent.
Everyone's laughing at Bloom in that bar, but we should be the ones laughing at them.
They think there is some easy uncomplicated definition of Irishness.
But in fact, Hank, the fundamental thing that all critical reading does is reveal to us that there are not easy
definitions that distinguish "us" from "them".
Reading with an eye toward metaphor allows us to become the person
we're reading about while reading about them.
That's why there are symbols and books and why your English teacher deserves your attention.
Ultimately it doesn't matter if the author intended a symbol to be there because the job of reading is not to
understand the author's intent;
the job of reading is to use stories as a way into seeing other people as we see ourselves.
And when we do that, we can look out at the world and see a giant
endless set of beautiful variations of pizzas! The whole world
composed of billions of beautiful delicious pizzas!
Hank, I'll see you on Wednesday.
Did I make that entire video so that I could eat one piece of pizza on my diet?
Maybe.